scientists in england say the fast
spreading covid19 variant first found in
the uk
is now evolving in a way that could make
existing vaccines
less effective the uk is keeping a close
eye on these mutations and it
leads the world in fact in tracking
changes in the genetic code of the virus
roxanna saberi is in london and shows us
what we here in the u.s actually can
learn
from the uk roxanna good morning to you
good morning tony people here in this
neighborhood are getting tested for the
variant first detected in south africa
and now scientists here are warning that
the uk variant
might be mutating in a way that mimics
it the good news is
this country has become very skilled at
hunting for mutations
england is racing to find and stop the
highly infectious south africa variant
of covet 19
before it's too late adding to the
urgency
scientists here have discovered that a
mutation in that variant
has now appeared in the uk variant
raising concern the virus is evolving
and could become more resistant to
vaccines
the virus over time is improving itself
it's a matter of natural selection it's
the survival of the fittest
issue sharon peacock leads a nationwide
network of scientists
tracking those transformations more
closely than anywhere else in the world
we're looking for mutations and that
those mutations really
give us a bar code for the virus
every day at labs like this one robots
and researchers sift through thousands
of samples of covet 19
mapping mutations in the genetic code
the sequence genome
and this is individual patient samples
last november they spotted something
alarming
23 mutations mainly in the spike protein
of the virus
allowing it to latch onto cells more
tightly making it much more contagious
that means for example if 10 people with
old variants of the virus could infect
13 others now they could infect around
20. that's really important because more
people can get sick and therefore
more people are likely to die simply
from the burden of disease
as what's since been dubbed the uk
variant has swept across the world
the u.s and many other nations have
tightened travel restrictions germany
and austria now mandate medical-grade
masks in most public places
and the uk has imposed a third
nationwide lockdown
as covet 19 mutates scientists here say
the world also needs to do more genetic
sequencing like this
they say in these efforts the u.s needs
to catch up
the u.s sequences less than one percent
of new samples
compared to around 10 percent in the uk
meaning many dangerous mutations
may be missed so these variants could be
more widespread than we know
very likely and i think that sequencing
is going to be vital in
detecting that
and scientists here also told us that
vaccines will likely need to be
redesigned by the end of this year
to adapt to new mutations gail got it
thank you roxanna siberia reporting from
london